okay guys Mississippi we're going to
talk about in a minute fasting and
ketosis qat there's a lot of little
questions I want to create one video to
explain everything so the first question
people keep asking is can I chew gum on
a ketogenic diet that's not going to be
significant at all it's so small and I
also recommend you do the xylitol gum
not the aspartate aspartame type gum
that everyone else does so yes you can
do some gum lemon water is that okay
totally fine
lemon juice is not a big factor at all
so tart but there's not a lot of sugar
wheatgrass juice powder I do wheatgrass
juice powder during the fast not a
problem
it's my multi vitamin mineral everything
okay
protein powders only with a meal because
it's protein so that will spike insulin
especially if it's low fat protein or
whey protein you want to add some fat to
it and then also have it after the meal
or during the meal but not as a snack a
cheat day well I already have a video on
that but no there's no such thing as a
cheat day on my program but because
here's the thing when you would do a
cheat day you pretty much are bumped out
of this ketosis for a period of time
because it takes a while to get into
ketosis it's going to take a while to
get back to ketosis so on some people
it's going to take three days to get
back on others it could even take a week
I'm not kidding so that could be a long
time so that could explain why you may
not be losing weight because you might
be doing a cheat day twice a week
nullifying everything it really depends
how much you cheat calories and two
meals like how do you fit in all your
calories into two meals or even one meal
well there's a kind of a balance you
don't want to stuff yourself to then
this huge meal where you're stuffed all
day you want to eat a really good
healthy meal make sure the food is
really nutrient dense the kale shakes I
always recommend because that has more
nutrition than other types of greens and
make sure it's like salmon that's a
higher quality than chicken and then you
may have to enhance with certain types
of nutrients but we're not necessarily
trying to stuff ourselves we're trying
to have two big meals and just till
you're satisfied and
or not the body will adapt to that many
calories there's a confusion that people
think that if they have less meals than
they're starving and it's going to slow
the metabolism that is not true
because you're doing nutrient-dense
meals if you do a small meal and you're
still hungry and it's like empty
calories or like five small meals of n2k
empty calories with sugar you're
definitely going to create kind of a
situation where you're going to be
hungry and craving all the time and your
metabolism will slow down simply because
you're cutting the calories that you're
covering the nutrients so the real key
is the nutrients so those meals that you
consume have to be robust large very
very complete there's I've created other
videos just on that one topic okay keto
rash now typically it's either two
situations either the liver is dumping
something and usually the reason for
that is that you're losing a lot of fat
a lot of the toxins in your body is
stored in the fat so a lot of times
those toxins can come out of the fat
circulate to the blood to the lymphatic
system and come out as a rash so one
thing the combat that is to consume a
large quantity of vegetables make sure
that's very high to kind of offset some
of the other fat burning that's
occurring but also bentonite clay you
can consume them on an empty stomach
bentonite clay is interesting because
it's like a little piece of clay that
does adsorption which is kind of like it
absorbs on the outside of the particle
20 no it's 2,000 times its weight so
it's like a very powerful magnet for
toxins or a sponge that will pull these
toxins so they don't leach out into the
tissues
okay bentonite clay okay apple cider
vinegar and lemon drink not a problem on
this on times of fasting go ahead and
consume that is not going to be an issue
will my cholesterol go up on some people
yes simply because the fat cell is
composed of cholesterol and
triglycerides
so your body can only burn the
triglycerides it doesn't burn
cholesterol so what happens some people
especially losing a lot of weight like
50 or 60 pounds and they have a lot of
weight to lose they could have a higher
level of cholesterol but I put a link
down below for you to get the complete
scoop on LDL HDL and total cholesterol
because you don't really have to worry
about it if you're doing this correctly
and you're doing a lot of vegetables
that's just the excess cholesterol
coming out of the fat cell that has to
come out has to go to the liver and be
dismantled to the gallbladder now the
keto flu or keto fatigue is basically a
situation where you're missing you're
depleting potassium and B vitamins so if
you were to put those back in either an
electrolyte powder or you can do
nutritional yeast that should handle it
like that other things that can happen
too which I don't want to get into that
detailed like you could have an issue
with more chance for a kidney stone for
example right well potassium citrate
will totally handle that and that's
that's only if you're not consuming
enough potassium from the vegetables
which I know is not the case because you
you know your vegetables do I recommend
either one of these during breastfeeding
not really because you don't want to do
a diet or you don't want to try to lose
weight when you're breastfeeding you
want to make sure max maximize the the
food there and not worry about doing too
much fasting especially since you have a
lot of stuff coming out from the fat
cell
same thing with pregnancy don't
recommend it just eat really healthy
during pregnancy and don't worry about
trying to lose weight or maintain your
weight the key thing with pregnancy and
this is the side note is make sure you
get take cod liver oil or some grass-fed
liver and I'm going to tell you why
because if you consume the right amount
of vitamin A not from a pill but from
food you can prevent a lot of issues
with dental arch problems overbite under
bite so you want your child to come out
so he or she does not get braces but has
good bone structure that's all the fat
soluble vitamins in the trace minerals
so make sure you can
trace minerals and fat fiber vitamins I
like cod liver oil and sea kelp is a
good one or a plant-based trace minerals
okay for kids can kids do this well if a
child is really overweight I probably
would put them on this but if they're
not I would put them on a version of
this and I actually recommend maybe some
fruit not this the extra sweet stuff but
I wouldn't be worried about berries
maybe bananas would be fine
but yeah that's maybe eat sweet potatoes
yams would be okay but other than that
if their their metabolism is so fast
they're going to need some type of
starch we're also going to get really
really skinny okay bulletproof coffee
question keeps coming out but sure that
can I do that well some people just have
it in the morning to sustain them and
that's not a problem but it is kind of
like a meal if you're adding fat or
coconut oil it is considered a meal and
it could potentially spike instant a
little bit so my whole point with this
is try it out and see if you're happy
with your results with weight loss try
it out for a week and then don't try it
for a week and see how it effects your
weight some people do really good some
people do not and I'll just make one
change maybe I'll cut down the butter
they put in there the coconut and bam
they just start really losing weight so
experiment on that but make sure you
don't do a lot of coffee simply because
it stimulates the adrenal so 1:00 in the
morning would be perfect now start as
milk if you want to put some organic
milk just a little bit it's not a big
deal okay kombucha tea if you're going
to do kombucha tea for most people it's
fine it does have ranges from two grams
of sugar up to like 10 grams of sugar
make sure it has no more than two grams
of sugar and make sure that's one
serving size and also that's another one
where it could potentially bump you out
of ketosis but it may not
so experiment but people that want to a
substitute for alcohol this is what I
would recommend drinking a champagne
glass is carbonated has the texture of
beer it will relax you but you don't
need much just do a little bit if you do
too much it can actually make you even
too acidic and it can throw off your ph
where your breathing is awful
little bit to keep you up at night okay
a lot of information just wanted to
cover these questions and let me know
what you think below put your comments
thanks for watching hi guys hey listen I
created a pretty amazing evaluation quiz
down below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause
so take the quiz now and we'll send you
a report